I think there's a lot of confusion in
any kind of school between I'm training
leadership people are gonna go into
leadership roles aren't returning people
going management and I just wondered how
you thought about these two things
what's the same what's different how do
they overlap I've always been a little
suspicious of the gap that's made
between in in the business literature
between management and leadership
because it often leads to one usually
management being demeaned right like we
don't need managers here we want leaders
here hold aside that I wouldn't use the
term managers and leaders but people in
these roles it demeans the whole
category of work if we could even parcel
out what those two are so I'm suspicious
of the the split or the
conceptualization of these two but if I
suspend that suspicion for a moment I
say okay what we're talking about here
for the moment is when we talk about
management we're talking about the
actual working and operations working of
a group and we talk about leadership
that we're talking about the role that
has to do with meaning and external
relations etc then my answer to that is
most people I know who work in
organizations do both of those things
that in a leadership manager or role in
a job supervisor vice president nurse
head of Nursing that most people talk
about both kinds of activities they come
and they say everything from helped me
manage my time more effectively help me
do performance appraisal which I would
call operational management things and
they say I need to inspire these people
I need to find a way to create meaning
for the people who are doing this so
that their emotional energy is brought
to the work not just their skill that's
a that
that's that's partly if we take this
split that's partly a leadership
function meaning inspiration vision and
I see the vast majority people that I
work with in all levels of organizations
struggling with quote-unquote leadership
issues as well as management issues so
I'm not sure that there's a meaningful
difference for me I think there's a set
of work that people in those roles do
and again if I'm faithful to the to the
to the view I'm talking about today some
people in those roles supervisor
vice-president are better at some of
those things and worse at some of those
things and they can't do it all alone
even the meaning and inspirational part
there are lots of examples of people in
leadership roles who weren't terribly
inspirational but somebody who was
working with them provided meaning and
inspiration to the to the part of the
social system or organization they were
working so given the educational systems
we have people go in one at a time and
they become educated what is your sense
of how we could do this better how could
we educate people to understand these as
roles and that they will play both roles
and that they will develop some
confidence in being able to play these
roles well you know my view is that we
again on this we don't have to work so
hard to create opportunities we just
have to utilize and mine the
opportunities we have so while it is
true let's take for example
undergraduate colleges it is true that
people come in as individuals they eat
sleep learn work together in groups a
classroom is a group it's a social
system it's often used it's often then
subdivided either for case work or
projects or whatever into groups whether
that's because it's it there's something
to be learned from working in groups or
it's just efficient in some ways but the
opportunities to use those experiences
dorm rooms undergraduate organizations
extra curricular to use all those
settings as ways of learning about the
self of ways of learning about other
groups of ways of learning about roles
and which one is in a leadership has
leadership responsibilities and roles
and which one has primarily followership
that's all there it's all present and I
think what's what's potential in in
places like that is to reflect on and
then begin to conceptualize what those
experiences are like and then learn
about the self in relationship to doing
those different kinds of roles so I
don't think it's I think it's our
orientation to the individual rather
than our lack of opportunity to learn
about this of these other dimensions
that's holding us back so I can see in
schools you have the technical role of
the school which are all the classes and
all the academics and everything you
just described is kind of around that
and I could see in a hospital you've got
the technical you trying to take care of
patients and do surgery and give the
right medications and there's a lot of
other stuff that goes on to families
come in and there's a lot of and maybe
in most organizations they're sort of
like a technical thing that has to be
done and somehow the way you've
described this it sounds as if the
leadership function or the development
of the leadership skills and experience
don't come straight from that technical
they it feels it particularly in school
so you're saying actually take advantage
of all these other things so my question
is how do we take what I think most
people think is the main thing a
university or college is doing or a
hospital is the technical stuff how do
we knit these together so that we can
develop leadership well I would probably
argue that that when your hands went
when you said the techne went like this
and I would say that the technical is
actually more like this that is take a
hospital who's delivering health care
it's lots of people the technical
healthcare so I have to draw blood I
have to send it to a lab I have to get
or take a photo by a technician and I
have to get it read so actually the core
activity of the institution is done by
relations
and so there is no way to parse out
unless one is merely an individual
crafts person making a silver cup even
then I would argue that there's some
relationships to produce to get to
provide the silver but certainly in
modern organizations which are defined
by specialization and then the
coordination of those specialized
functions or tasks which is I think part
of what leadership does you can have a
core test that doesn't have these kinds
of coordinated relationships and as part
of the essent essential core of most
order modern organizations since we left
the craft guilds I think that's what
modern organization is I think that's
where we are and the good news is it
means if we turn our attention to it we
can focus on what makes those
relationships work better and worse and
what the different people's roles are in
making those work better so you're sort
of saying the opportunities are right in
front of us but maybe some organizations
don't sort of take advantage of the
opportunities that are right there right
and I think that partly because we're so
focused on the individuals we don't lift
up our gaze and say gee how these
individuals function is influenced
heavily by the relationships that they
find themselves in now we know that most
of us know how important relationships
are to our own creativity produc product
ibbity performance but somehow when we
get into organisations we tend to focus
on individuals well I have to say I'm
really interested in how you frame this
because the first three things are so
difficult to do that you sort of
recommended to really know you've got to
do this with other people and know your
own weaknesses and think through your
own biases those are all so complicated
and then you are comforting to say the
opportunity to do something about this
is right in front of us all the time the
opportunity to think of more than our
individual technical role but that it is
de facto already in relationship and how
do we learn from that if we have a
moment maybe my most comforting thought
to myself as well as to others is that
it is precisely our limitation
and weaknesses that make possible the
kinds of productive relationships
between those in leadership roles and
followership roles that actually our
limitations and weaknesses are the
opportunity when I ask a workshop of
people if they've ever been in a
relationship with a boss who
meaningfully revealed to them a
limitation or weakness for which they
needed this subordinate to contribute
his or her expertise and a bunch of
hands go up I say how many people felt
more connected to that relationship as a
result of that disclosure all the hands
going I've done this thousand times
there may be two hands that say that
people felt less loyal committed
involved and engaged and so I think the
comforting thing is actually in spite of
our terror and fear the more we can do
this the more we create relationships
that are that are but not only effective
but more committed and more meaningful
hmm I think you've given us a huge
amount to think about and I hope we can
do this again great thank you so much
thanks to everybody who's been joining
we hope that this has been helpful and
may be the first of several such
sessions
you